all right coming to you live from a from
a hotel in in Tallahassee Florida you
know you know people ask me all the time
why I do these shows in a you know I'm
in a car one minute and then the next
minute I'm in a in my house sometimes
I'm in a hotel sometimes I'm riding a
camel through the through the desert you
know sometimes I'm on a boat with a goat
sam-i-am
you know people say well why are you why
you're all over the place and I think
it's a pretty simple answer to that
question the answer is because I just I
I just do it wherever I am I just do the
show wherever I happen to be but it's
just it's interesting to me that some
people get so upset about that they get
very upset about the scenery especially
when I'm in the car because I have been
known on many occasions to do the show
in my car and then just read the
comments anytime because there's always
gonna be people who are really angry
about the fact that I mean I can't watch
this if you're in the car get out of the
car why are you in the car stop being in
the car why is he in the car what's with
the car over and over and over again and
I just look just take it easy
it reads if I was in your car I
understand being upset I don't
understand being upset about a guy in a
car I just I don't understand it but I'm
not in a car today anyway at least I'm
in a you know you know on the inside I'm
in a physical building alright a few
things I want to talk about today the
first thing the the daily wire as you as
you may know does not publish the names
of of scumbag mass killers anymore like
the one who committed that terrible
attack in California yesterday and I
think that's the the right approach and
I wish that's what I was thinking about
today is I really wish everyone in the
media could we could kind of all be on
the same page here and I know that so
few of us can agree just in general and
society few of us can agree on anything
and in the media especially everything
is fractured down ideological and
political lines of course but maybe this
is one thing that week we should be able
to agree on you know
but obviously we aren't there yet so
after the attack California that killed
12 people wounded many more the name and
face and biographical details of the
coward responsible for the act were
plastered all over every news site and a
lot of the TV channels his name was
trending on social media so on and so
forth and I'm sure if you typed his name
into Google there would be hundreds of
results all ready for it
now look I'm you know I'm realistic and
I know that we're never gonna reach a
point where literally every source of
news or information on television or on
the Internet commits to making these
people anonymous and and I'm in you know
the daily wire we only change this
policy in the last year so there is an
argument to be made for publishing the
names in the faces I don't deny that and
it is possible for a website our news
channel to do that for reasons that are
not simply pure exploitation and I'm not
sure that complete anonymity would even
be ideal anyway even if it was possible
to do even if it were possible
theoretically to get to a point where
nobody is talking about no one reports
on the name no one puts the picture out
there even if that were possible that
complete anonymity would not which it
isn't but even if it were I'd say that I
don't think that would be ideal either
because the personal details of mass
killers can be relevant and important to
some people in some circumstances for
instance if you read about the
background of one of these people and
then you say to yourself well that
sounds an awful lot like my teenage son
or something then I think it becomes
important information there are other
situations as well where it can be
important the point is that that that
the information about these people can
be important it can be useful it does
help to know what sort of people we're
dealing with it does help can help to
honestly try to understand what led to
these attacks not to excuse them in the
least obviously but just to figure out
what we can be done in the future to
prevent them but there is a difference
between this information being made
available
and that's one thing having the
information available of course that
makes it but is there between that and
the breathless kind of coverage that you
see about these people the obsession
with personal details the tabloid like
approach that some websites and news
organizations use the information can be
made accessible without putting a
humungous picture of the guy's face on
the front page for instance so I think
that's something that everyone in the
media needs to look at and decide where
the balance is because I don't I don't
think we've quite struck the balance
there's no question I think the media
this is one thing I need to think of
media in general has gotten better at as
we've all assessed this and realized
we've realized that there's simply no
question that these people are motivated
in part by a deep desire for attention
for infamy and many criminologist
psychologists have been warning about
this repeatedly for a very long time
these people having failed to figure out
how to live whole and fruitful lives and
they feel like their very identity is
fading away into this pitiful fog of
irrelevance and mediocrity so then they
try to assert their existence and claim
some kind of meaning through an act of
random destruction so the more attention
we award people like that when they do
it the more we incentivize the next
pathetic loser to follow in their
footsteps I just think it's it's hard
maybe for us it's hard to overestimate
and maybe it's hard for us to understand
just how deeply these deranged lunatics
crave to be noticed and noticed in
horrible ways so I think if we focused
on on other things after these attacks
and maybe the next attention-starved
madman would be slightly less inclined
to to forfeit his life just to become a
faceless footnote on another very
terrible chapter of American history and
I and as I said do you think this is one
area one area where some people in media
making some progress but I think we just
have to keep looking at that and
assessing that all right we're now
hearing more details about the ante fuh
someone told me it's pronounced an tyfa
I don't really care I'm calling it an
tyfa more details about the antifa quote
demonstration at Tucker Carlson's house
in DC last night there was a mob of
about 20 left-wing thugs and they came
in on to Carlson's property when his
wife was at home he also has four kids
who apparently were not at home thank
God but it could have been for all these
people cares people probably want we're
hoping that they would be on so they
could terrify them and they started
banging on on his door managed to crack
it in the process they were shouting we
know where you sleep at night somebody
in the crowd was talking about bringing
a pipe bomb they spray-painted an
anarchy symbol on his driveway a twitter
account that was associated with the
group posted a message on twitter while
this was going on this is what the
message said it's a racist scumbag leave
town every night you spread fear into
our homes fear of the other fear of us
fear of them each night you tell us we
are not safe tonight you're reminded
that we have a voice tonight we remind
you that you are not safe either and
then the group also apparently posted
the names and addresses of Carlson's
brother and and friend as well let's
just be completely clear about one thing
this is not a protest this is not a
protest is this is not free speech these
are not activists these are terrorists
who are engaged in an organized campaign
to harass and threaten their political
enemies that's that's terrorism by
definition they're being very upfront
about it they're saying this is what
they wanted they want to terrify they
want they want people to feel unsafe and
this of course is far from the first
case that we've seen we've seen this all
time with this with this group we've
seen them shut down entire city blocks
assault innocent bystanders vandalized
property like they did at our Carlson's
house we've seen them swarm politician
chase them out of restaurants like they
did to like they did take this this
exact same group in DC did that to Ted
Cruz
we've seen them riots in their stupid
little ski masks in the street with you
know carrying around bats and clubs and
everything there's a reason why the
Department of Homeland Security has
classified these people domestic
terrorists because this again is
politically motivated violence
incitement and harassment that's what
terrorism is but the problem is that
they aren't treated like terrorists for
some reason that usually they're allowed
to carry on unimpeded it still boggles
my mind that anyone can show up to a
protest with a bat in a ski mask and not
be immediately arrested that's not free
speech free speech does not require you
to carry a bat and have a ski mask on
and in fact I would say if this is if
whatever speech you're engaging in if
you aren't willing to do it with your
actual face visible then you shouldn't
be doing it that's that's a really good
sign that whatever kind of speech you're
about to engage in clearly is not
legitimate free speech because any
legitimate free speech if you're going
to do it out in public you should be
required to do it with your face visible
but this is this is they're given this
incredible leeway to just like do
essentially do whatever they want and I
don't understand it
the cops did show up to Tucker Carlson's
house last night after after his wife
called them but I haven't heard reports
of mass arrests going on I'm not was
anybody arrested I'm actually not sure
about that I I certainly don't think
they were all arrested if they were them
I apologize for getting it wrong but my
impression is that they were not all
arrested if anyone was arrested but how
does that happen
why don't the police show up and just
arrest everybody you've got this violent
mob outside somebody's house they've
already gone on his private property
that vandalized they're shouting making
threats I'll rest everybody there or if
you've got a mob in the street
assaulting bystanders you got them with
masks just arrest all of them
immediately what what are we waiting for
it
seems like the strategy is okay let's
wait until let's wait until they kill
somebody
and we're cuz they haven't killed
anybody yet and so let's wait until they
do that but I think you know I I think
maybe you'll be better to to head them
off at the pass because we see where
this is headed
groups like this you know they either
become more and more violent as time
goes on or they are suppressed and
stamped out I'm not aware of any case
where a group like an auntie feh this
kind of organization sort of
organization did a course correction on
their own and then trended back in the
other direction towards non-violence I'm
not aware of that ever happening maybe
there is an example I'm not aware of it
so what are we waiting for
why are these ski masks terrorists
allowed to get past square one
it seems to me especially at the Hope
Department Homeland Security considers
them to be domestic terrorists as soon
as they show up arrest them because this
is a violent organization they have made
it clear that's what that's their their
goal is to make people feel is to
terrorize and to threaten which is not
legitimate speech and these are by the
way these are the very same people who
argue that white supremacist don't have
free speech because to to to spew white
supremacist rhetoric is not legitimate
speech you don't have a right to it now
the problem is that they consider any
speech they disagree with to be white
supremacists so everybody who is not one
of them as a white supremacist because
these are ridiculous fools but even in
the case of an actual white supremacist
their argument is even if white
supremacist is standing up and speaking
his mind peacefully he's not he's not
directly threatening any individual
person they're saying that's not
legitimate speech well we can argue
about that but but let me tell you
something if that's not legitimate
speech if you're telling you that person
doesn't have a right to it then you
certainly don't have a right to to stand
in the street and make explicit threats
towards individuals
one other thing I want to talk about
related to all this somewhat related I
mentioned yesterday a tweet that I sent
out which was relatively innocuous I
thought I just made the point couple
days ago that before the election I made
the point that your daily life and and
my daily life is not really going to be
affected terribly affected one way or
another
by the outcome of the election elections
are important they're not the most
important thing politicians are powerful
but they're not gods and that's the way
our system was set up by the very
brilliant men who established it it set
up that way so that even if you have a
bunch of incompetent idiots and
partisans
in government which which which we which
we always have had to some extent or
another even in that case you're still
going to basically have freedom you can
go about your life and live your life
but as I said yesterday that tweet
provoked an extremely strong reaction
from the left thousands of outraged
comments and messages poured in
including actual death threats death
threats because I said that elections
are not as important as everyone thinks
they were death threats because of that
one guy said that if he catches me in a
room alone I'm not gonna be breathing
anymore which was his way of threatening
to kill me another said that he hopes
that somebody burns down my house there
were other a lot of other messages in
that vein and then there were others
that weren't threatening but we're still
pretty atrocious someone messaged me
just recently and said that I'm a bad
person and a bad father and my daughter
deserves a better father by the way
here's the exact tweet which they were
responding to the tweet was elections
are important but no matter who wins
99.99% of your daily life in existence
will be completely unaffected by the
results today just a bit of perspective
now even if you disagree with that why
in the world would it make you mad
enough to wish or threaten harm why
would your response to that benign and
knock you asst statement be I hope
someone burns down your house I use this
just as a personal example because it's
the most reason I could point to dozens
of others of course but the point is
that none of these it
examples are even necessary because you
you know you you you know how it goes
right you've seen this as well when
people disagree on the Internet
they threaten you death they call you a
bad person they call you a Nazi etc etc
we're so used to this dynamic by now
that that we're so used to this dynamic
especially on the on the internet that
we think it doesn't count
we say well that's just the Internet
people aren't like that in real life I'm
told that all the time I put a
screenshot of that tweet of someone
saying they hope someone burns down my
house yesterday and a few people told me
that say well it's just the internet
though you know it's not how people are
in the real world you got to get off the
internet and go out into the real world
now it is easy to come to that concludes
easy to come to this kind of Duelist
idea of there's the internet there are
internet people and then regular people
right because if you're like me you're
your everyday interactions with people
are normal and you get along fine with
most people in real life even though
there is this animosity under the
surface apparently it doesn't really
come out most of the time this is one of
the things that I've noticed and
throughout my career is that I'll get
the vilest most disgusting emails from
people and messages but then when I'm
out in public for the most part people
are perfectly friendly unless I've um
protested or something like that but
that but that's a group of people right
it's so groups can act that way people
on the internet act but when you've got
individual people in their everyday life
most of them act perfectly fine so how
do you account for that for all of the
hate and the vitriol online and in
groups but that doesn't counter carry
over to everyday life and everyday
interactions well it seems obvious
enough this is these are cowards
cowardice plays a large part here people
want the insulation and the protection
of a computer screen or a mob there are
other things that work here too
obviously but but I think that's one of
the main things but what that is what
I'm saying is that tells us something
about what's going on in
people it tells us something about the
the the capacity the the tendency of
people now they might keep it contained
and they might funnel it through their
keyboards but it's still there and
that's why I never quite understand the
people who say well yeah all of that
hate is just people online you gotta get
offline go out into the real world
well what who do you think these people
are who are typing this stuff online
where do you think it's coming from
these are actual human beings saying
this some of them might be BOTS but most
of them are real people so what does
that mean well that's not the real world
of course it's the real world it's not
it's not a it's not some kind of dream
world you're not dreaming when you're
online you're interacting with real
actual people in fact I would and I'm
afraid to say this because I know I know
what kind of statement it is about the
state of society but I actually would
say that your interactions with people
online are a better indication of how
people actually are in the state of our
culture then your interactions with
people when you're in line at the
grocery store or something it's a better
it gives you a better sense because
number one it's a bigger sample size
right when you're online you're
interacting with a lot of different
people wants bigger sample size and also
the anonymity gives people the license
they feel like to actually let their
true cells show so a guy who leaves a
comment under a YouTube video saying I
hope your children get cancer and then
he goes out and and and you bump into
him you know you walk by him when he's
mowing his lawn or something any waves
friendly to you well that's not that
doesn't prove that he's not the guy who
said that he's still the kind of guy who
would say something like that he's just
too afraid too much of a coward to say
to somebody in person but that's still
what's so no you so you walk by some of
your wave to me say oh well that see
it's a decent guy people are decent no
that's not a decent guy if you become
suddenly very indecent and vile and
disgusting when you get online then you
are an indecent vile disgusting human
even if it never comes
except online the Internet is just a
medium for communication it doesn't it
doesn't relieve you of your moral guilt
if you if you say and do horrible things
online it that would be like if somebody
wrote a horrible message to you on a
piece of loose-leaf and left it on your
doorstep and you read it and you were
upset you said look at this terrible
thing someone and I said no no but
that's not that's not the real world
that's just paper well the paper didn't
write it did it a real person wrote that
a real person was using this as a
platform to let you know their true
feelings inside so that does give you an
insight into who that person is not just
who that person is when they're writing
on paper who that person is period so
this is I just feel like this is one
area of false comfort that we try to
give ourselves where we say yeah you
know you can't you can't voice any
opinion online without a bunch of rabid
morons attacking you but that doesn't
mean that the country is actually filled
with rabid morons you know because
people are decent in real life no that
is real life that is real life what is
the actual percentage or what's the
actual ratio of normal decent people to
rabid morons I have no idea I have no
idea it probably is lower than what it
seems like when you're online but it's
definitely higher than what it seems
like when you're going about your daily
life because people have learned to
channel their
they're rabid more honest through the
internet which you might say has certain
advantages it's sort of like a cyber
purge that goes on every day it's like
the purge but online every single day
where people could just let out all of
their horrible feelings and thoughts and
become monsters online so that doesn't
so that they can be you know they can
get all that bad energy out but I think
what we're seeing is it's starting to
spill over more and more into the real
world into our physical everyday life so
it's kind of a depressing thought but I
think that's that's kind of where we are
there is just a lot of animosity out
there and not just animosity but what I
what I encounter is one of the main
features I guess of the way that we that
we have debates and discussions in
America and yeah it's mostly like this
online but again that's just the
reflection of how people actually are is
people are they're filled with hate
animosity - very hostile but on top of
that there is this total unwillingness
that a lot of people have a total
unwillingness to actually listen to what
somebody is saying and try to understand
it and then engage with it I think what
we are seeing now in our culture is they
is among a lot of people a complete
unwillingness to do that so it's just a
breakdown of communication if you're not
willing to listen to someone and
actually try to understand what they're
saying then there's just there's no hope
of any of any actual communication
happening of any fruitful communication
happening anyway it seems like in most
arguments now people are it seems like
they're yelling at each other but really
they're yelling at the voices in their
own head because they've created this
caricature of what they think the other
side is like and what they think the
other person is going to say and what
they think the other person means when
they say things and they are just
superimposing that
on to the statements that the other
person actually makes so this tweet was
just one example of that I don't know
what I actually said was benign and
innocuous I but the people reading it
they obviously had it in their head they
were hallucinating they had a something
else in mind
I don't know what they read I don't know
what they think that I wrote but they
are taking their impressions of the kind
of person I must be based on my politics
and they are creating a point of view I
don't actually have and imposing that on
to me and then shouting at it
that's what discussion is in America now
pray for our country everybody I'll
leave it there talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed